hello everyone and welcome to this
tutorial on tableau for data science
we're gonna cover a few basic features
of tableau and how I use it for data
science and how it can kind of fit into
your workflow here's an example of a
data science workflow we have in this
example six different components and
this is going to be different you know
depending on what type of environment
you're working in but generally you're
gonna have the data collection data
exploration sort of the data wrangling
data munging stage where you have to
pull everything together and clean it
for modeling and then the next step
would be modeling validation and then
reporting so the way I use tableau
primarily is in the exploration phase
and then in the reporting phase so the
expiration I want to basically be able
to look at the data once I collect it I
want to be able to look at the different
variables that exist I want to see you
know how the data is distributed for
example for each variable I want to see
if there's any outliers or anything like
that that I want to kick out from the
the modeling because you know if you
feed bad data into this model you're
gonna get some you know your garbage in
garbage out so being able to explore the
data I find is really helpful and
sometimes that's really all you need to
know if you should move forward or not
you know if you're trying to look to see
if there's some kind of a relationship
between variables
sometimes a quick exploration and Pat
blow a nice visual will help give you
that and then also in the reporting side
so once you've built your model you
validated it and you want to be able to
share your results with others tableau
is also you know ideal for that they
have great reporting tools it doesn't
matter really what kind of organization
you're in you you can pass if you have
tableau server or or not you can you can
pass your workbooks on to others so that
they can view them as well
so what is tableau so we kind of covered
it briefly in the last slide but it's
just a business intelligent / data
visualization tool that allows you to
make sense of your data really by
looking at it right I mean sometimes
we're looking at millions of rows of
data you could check maybe the first
hundred or you know first few thousand
and look at the data but that's really
not efficient and it's really not it's
really not feasible these days to be
able to just look at the data and figure
out what's going on with big data and
there's millions tens of millions of
rows billions of rows potentially and
being able to throw this stuff quickly
into a tool like tableau and look at it
really really helps a lot so here you
have tableau desktop and then the server
version so the DEP we're going to be
using the desktop version today
specifically tableau public which is
free you can download it for free from
their website and that's just a software
that you download to your computer and
then the server version actually is
within the browser you can create charts
and dashboards and then upload that to
the server for consumption throughout
your organization so the interface here
for tableau desktop is really just
drag-and-drop it reminds me of a pivot
table in Excel so you drag you know the
columns and rows around to get what you
want and and the way that this works is
these are the fields here and it's
broken down into dimensions and measures
so dimension I think of a dimension is
basically a category or a categorical
variable and then a measure is a
numerical value so it could be the
number of records it could be any number
of things and then here you have a
filter you can apply a filter here and
I'll show you how to use this section
later the filter in the Mark section but
moving over here here's where you placed
your columns and rows so if I want to
basically show in column form I want to
be able to let's just say pulley and
current status here to the columns and
the number of records to the row then it
would give me
status categories along the x-axis and
then the volumes for that category along
the y-axis here so we're gonna go over
this with the live demo here but just
want to give you a brief introduction to
the interface and and how it's set up
and this is the end result
you know once you're able to make a few
charts you could pull it together and
make a dashboard like this for example
so now we're going to go ahead and
download tableau public I've just
googled tableau public here and you're
gonna have to put in your your email
address here to download the app go
ahead and put mine in there and download
it it may take a while depending on your
internet speed it's generally pretty
quick so go ahead and install
on your computer
I'm gonna fast forward the video here so
that you don't have to watch this entire
install but feel free to pause the video
and hit play again when you're ready to
go okay so now I've downloaded tableau
public I have a shortcut here was
installed on my desktop and here we
needed to connect to a file so it gives
you several options here excel txt JSON
access PDF spatial or statistical file
and the difference between the tableau
public version and the tableau desktop
which is the paid version it's about
eight hundred and fifty dollars is that
you're you're limited to just a handful
of inputs here and just a handful of
file types the desktop version really
has has more options here and you can't
you know you can connect to a server
like a sure or any sort of cloud
environment so AWS Azure a Google cloud
and pull your data in directly from
there here so we need to go ahead and
get our data set and the data set I'm
going to use for this tutorial is the
Titanic data set from kaggle and I'll
include links to tableau public and this
data set in the video description you
just click on that and you'll probably
have to sign up if you don't have a
Kaggle account already and basically
what this is is Kaggle is it is
essentially just sort of the online
olympics for data nerds you you have
competitions for machine learning deep
learning models companies can actually
host their their data sets on Kaggle and
have basically the best data scientists
in the world compete to build the best
model and and the winner can actually
earn money so it's pretty cool so we're
gonna go ahead and i've already got an
account so i'm gonna sign in here and
once you're logged in you can go to the
data tab here and then we're gonna
actually use
dot CSV go ahead and download that I'm
just gonna go ahead and move that to my
desktop and now we're going to connect
to that CSV file so it looks like an
excel file but it's really a flat CSV
file test-1 so we're going to use a txt
file input here now we get to the
desktop pull that in and once you open
tableau public and import your data set
it's basically just going to show you
all of the data fields that exist and
you may not know what those what those
are so passenger ID survived passenger
class name example for example so kaggle
actually has a data dictionary here on
the data set page so survival is a
categorical variable one standing for
yes - meaning no that they didn't
survive passenger class is the ticket
class so first second third class sex is
the gender male or female agent years
number of siblings parents children
above the Titanic for the following
variables and then ticket pick a number
fare cabin number so the cabin number
could be indicative of where they were
located on the ship and then embarked is
there a port of embarkation so just just
looking at this data dictionary you can
kind of get a feel for which variables
might be useful in which variables may
not be useful at all
so survival obviously is very important
we wouldn't look at the correlation
between these variables these other
variables and whether or not the
passenger survived so now we're going to
go back to tableau passenger ID that's
going to be probably not very useful
survive that's gonna be very important
passenger class passenger name is not
going to be very important
the ticket number is unlikely to be
significant fair that's how much they
paid cabin number and embarked so you
can see we have all of these columns
here and you can always reference the
data dictionary so we're gonna go ahead
and click on sheet1 at the bottom and
you can look how tableau automatically
pulls in these different variables so
they it makes a determination based on
the type of data being pulled in whether
it should be a dimension or a measure so
in this class I'm sorry in this example
we're going to really just want to look
at the number of Records and how the
number of Records relate to these
different categories and whether the
passengers survived so we're going to
actually go ahead and make all of these
at dimension so for age to become a
dimension we may put that in two
different bins so if I want to do that
automatically for example if I wanted to
choose an age range let me go ahead and
give an example here I want to show this
going down you can see here that it's
it's just a measure here so it's adding
up all the ages but what I really want
to see is you know is there sort of a
correlation between the age and whether
or not the person survived so we we
actually want to create a measure based
on this age measure create a dimension
I'm sorry based on this age measure and
we can do that automatically by creating
bins so we can call it age bin and the
size of the bin is basically the number
of years between each bucket I'll just
do ten years and if we pull that in
there you see we have a null value we'll
go ahead and pull in the number of
Records and then circle back to that
null so here we go we have a
distribution of all passengers on the
Titanic we're gonna go ahead and pull
out the null here it's very important to
note that
when I pull this over I'm not just
clicking on it and pulling it over I'm
hitting on a PC control on a Mac you
would use the command button and then
left-click at the same time and pulling
this field over to the filters bar and
if I uncheck the null value there apply
and then okay that gives me the
distribution without the null values so
this is great but you know I want to
have some context here by adding
percentages so if I take a number of
records here again and pull it up to the
rows bar and then hit this down arrow
here and you basically have this drop
down and then quick table calculation
and then percent of total okay so now
what that did is add we have the volumes
here above and then the percent of total
below but I really don't have any labels
so I need to add the labels here so this
makes sense in the marks bar this
basically allows you to change the
coloring the labels the size of your
chart and you have three in this example
you have three sections you have all
this section which is the summation of
all the records and then this bottom one
represents the basically the percent of
total so for the second one we want to
go ahead and pull in the labels here to
add the labels the column labels to each
each bar so I'm going to hit ctrl on my
PC command on a Mac and then left-click
hold those together and then drag it
over to the labels box and you can see
that it adds the labels there I'm going
to do the same thing now but for the
bottom section and the percent of total
control left click hold and then move it
down to the labels section you can see
now on top we have the volumes and then
the percentage of the total number of
records below
so this is great but what it really
doesn't give us is whether you know we
want to know if age was an influencing
variable on whether or not the passenger
survived so we're going to use the
survived variable here and it's a
measure tab loge treated that as a
measure when it pulled it in to the data
set but we really want to treat that as
a categorical variable so we want to
convert it from a measure to a dimension
and the way you do that is you hover
over the variable and click down here
and then convert to dimension so now
that's a dimension it moves up to four
measures up to the dimension section and
we want to color these bars based on
whether the passengers survived or not
so I'm going to hold down control and
then left-click on my PC command
left-click on the Mac in order to drag
this field over but I want to do I want
to apply that color to both sections so
I'm going to click on the all marks box
here and then click on it control left
click hold and then drag that over to
color and then you can see this legend
pops up over here on the right and what
that represents is if it's orange then
that represents a survivor the survivor
portion of the population and blue is
the non survivor population so you can
see what the distribution looks like
here in terms of the total number of
records by age bin and then you can
compare you know each ratio the
percentage each age bucket to see if
that age grouping had a disproportionate
survival rate relative to all the
passengers so this is great we're gonna
call this I'm going to rename this tab
so I just double clicked here on the
sheet and we'll call it age okay and now
the good part
we've already built this out so we don't
have to redo this for every variable so
I'm gonna right click here and then
duplicate and so what I'm gonna do now
is just swap out age for another
variable so in this case we're gonna use
passenger class so I want to get rid of
age bin so I what I did to get rid of
that is I just clicked on it left
clicked no ctrl or command button just
and then just dragged it below and that
get you know that removed it from the
filter and I can do the same thing here
just drag it away and here we're just
stuck with you know left with these
summations of each each category here so
now I want to add passenger class this
also was treated as a measure so we want
to convert that to a dimension drag that
over we only have three classes here I
can drag this over this chart to expand
it so it makes more sense we do not have
any null values here which is great and
you can see that it automatically
populates everything so that's that's
great
we can change the name here to peak
class to represent passenger class
duplicate that
and parents of children let's look at
that number parents children aboard the
Titanic number of siblings spouses
aboard the Titanic we're gonna look at
sibling spouse's will convert that to a
dimension swap that out there we go
rename this sibling spouse and I'm gonna
create one more chart one more sheet and
it's basically going to be whether or
not they survive just to get a feel for
you know out of all the passengers how
many survived so I'm going to pull over
the survived variable here and then
number of Records and this does not look
very nice right so we can actually
change the chart type over here if you
click on show me over here in the top
right corner I'm going to actually just
create a pie chart I feel like that
makes a lot of sense for this type of
information you know it's going to be
one or the other they survived or they
didn't survive and I can drag that out
to make it a little bit bigger and when
you click on the pie chart option here
it automatically adds these labels and
what I can do in order to add the labels
to the visual itself is control left
click and drag that up to the label
command left click if you're on a Mac
and then you can add okay so that worked
now I want to add survived the one in
the zero so one represents a survivor
zero represents a non survivor will name
that sheet survived
okay so now we have four sheets we have
aged passenger class sibling spouse and
survived and that's great we can
actually use this information to create
a dashboard in tableau and I'm going to
get that to that in a second but what I
want to cover very quickly is how to
create your own measure okay so I'm
going to use age for this I'm going to
instead of using the bins create a
calculated field we'll call it custom
age bins we're going to say
if age it's less than or equal to 10
then 0 to 10 else if age greater than 10
and age less than or equal to let's just
say 20 and 11 to 20
else if you get the idea I'm not gonna
do this for every age bucket will just
want everybody else in over over 20
we'll just put them in 20 plus so
they're 20 years plus and then if I add
the end there
I've got elsif in an else so I mean I'd
and remove else if instead I have an
Ellis which will be the catch-all at the
end if it isn't fall within one of these
buckets and then the end of the
statement
apply and now I'm going to duplicate the
age tab for this example and swap out
age bin for my custom age group custom
age bin so now you can see it's 0
through 10 11 through 20 20 plus and you
know we can use the bin function to do
that really quickly I think the point of
that exercise was to show you how to
create a calculated field so I really
don't need that anymore so I'm going to
delete it so now we want to take these
sheets that we've created and we want to
make a dashboard okay so to do that you
can see these three tabs here below with
the little chart there and then the four
boxes and then what's called a story we
want to click on the dashboard by the
new dashboard button okay so what this
does is creates a blank canvas for us to
create a dashboard and this thing always
for whatever reason the size is always
wrong so I just change it you click on
this little down arrow here and then the
other one right below it and choose
automatic and it expands it to fit your
screen and then we just double click
each of these sheets it's age class
sibling survived okay that was really
fast really easy to kind of pull this
stuff together and add it to a dashboard
and I don't like this number of Records
thing every I can click on it and
check you know if the X and it will
remove it and let's say I want to have
survived up here on the top section I
can move I can move that around you can
drag and drop these sections to fit your
needs there we go
let's say I want to expand this some you
can actually just hover your mouse out a
little ways and drag that so that it
stands out a little bit more and you can
change the colors here so I can change
the survived or non survived I'm going
to change that to green director you
know I'm sorry I changed the one to
green to represent that they survived
and then the zero to red I could do that
here and it will change all of them
there you go
it's a nice Christmas colors but we can
drag this over as well make it fit more
symmetrical and then increase the size
of this as well and reposition it so we
just in a matter of minutes we're able
to create sheets and then a dashboard
and that's really fantastic I don't all
these other tools that you could use
like clique or d3 or I I don't know it
takes a while it's it you got to know
how to code in those software programs
in order to make the visualizations and
it you know it's just a pain so the
thing I like about tableau it's it's
it's really easy I compare it to two
like an iPhone where people someone a
child can basically pick up an iPhone
and immediately start using it it's that
intuitive you know tableau is that way
for visualization it's really that
simple you just literally drag and drop
until you get what you want so I really
actually don't like these colors
especially the red maybe we'll just add
the blue bag
okay that's a little bit better anyway
we only dealt with a few of these
variables here you can get a feel for
you know how many people survived you
know it looks like and we could actually
add the percentages here as well but it
looks like you know most people did not
survive so it's really sad and you can
look at at this chart here and say you
know out of the people that did survive
it looks like you know if they're
between the ages of 20 and 30 you had a
better success rate there and for the
passenger classes it looks like if you
were you know in the first class you had
a better shot you know fifteen percent
versus you know less than ten percent
here and then 13 percent here and
siblings and spouses those that had I
guess fewer siblings and spouses they
they survived at a higher rate which is
obviously pretty sad but this this
really kind of brings to life the data
we we all know what happened with the
Titanic and if we were to just look at
this data here in the data source you
know just looking at this you know
there's only 891 rows you might be able
to even look at this and sort of pick up
some trends but what if that number was
8 million rows right there's no way you
could could go through that data and
honestly there's no way you could get
this data into Excel I know they have
excels gotten better but just the
expedience with which you can pull data
in and look at it I don't not sure that
you could do that with any other
software that's available and then
quickly create these sheets and
dashboards so and thanks for watching
[Music]